thinking back to that sunny day sitting
in a coffee shop talking with my friends
about how we should be doing more to
tackle climate change
we knew we wanted to address fast
fashion but we needed more than just a
vague topic for our solidarity project
to help us develop the idea further we
used a technique called the problem and
solution tree
it helped us to better understand the
issue and its possible causes and
effects leading us to more concrete
ideas for technical topic
here is how it works
first you identify the main problem that
you want to address
for us it was the environmental impact
of the fast fashion industry
this problem is represented as the trunk
of the tree
and task goes into the middle of the
paper
the roots of our problem go into well
the roots of the tree
in our discussions we identified some of
the main causes of this issue to be
financial barriers
educational barriers and social
pressures
finally the branches are where we see
the effects of the issue
this is what the roots and the trunk
have ultimately produced for example by
not being aware of the problem the
industry thrives creating tons of
non-recyclable waste filling our oceans
with microplastics while also creating
an ever-growing need for more clothes
created from non-renewable resources
continuing the cycle
it's not exactly a pretty looking tree
is it
with the second tree the trunk now
represents the desired outcome that we
want to see
for our project we wanted consumers to
be aware of their choices and the
respective consequences
we've wanted to encourage a repair
before we replace mentality as the roots
are the pathways to the outcome
this is where we wrote down ideas of
action and activities that we could do
to reach our goal for example
organizing workshops to teach people how
to repair clothes
creating online content to provide
reliable information
or giving speeches to raise awareness
finally the branches of the solution
tree represent the impact that these
activities could lead to for example
with new sewing skills people might be
more willing to repair their clothes
before throwing them away
if people knew the reality of the
industry perhaps they would think twice
before buying three new shirts when they
only need one
it was useful to explore these trees as
a team because each new idea on the
problem tree gave us new ideas for the
actions and impacts we wanted to see in
our solution tree once the trees were
finished we show them to our friends and
family to see if the problems in the
solution match their realities or if
there were roots and branches that we
had overlooked
this is something that helped us and we
think it will help you too
[Music]
you